I was going to talk to you a little bit
about AI artificial intelligence you
know you watch the news and they go
artif this is it it's over for Humanity
artificial intelligence is taking over
and um they even say like there's an
artificial intelligence program now
let's say you can't write a speech uh
the the artificial intelligence you plug
in a couple of names and a couple of
bits of information in the aisle right
either a song or a speech or a they can
do anything so now they can even pass
the bar exam for you from what I
understand they're saying that it's a
better lawyer than a human being you
know what I mean better legal documents
for sure so there's a a thing called a
chat GPT which that's the one yeah
that's already out our guys were messing
around with it they fed in clips of our
show and they said all right all right
artificial intelligence to a Howard and
Robin uh you know opening to the show
I'll tell you I don't think we're going
to be replaced anytime soon with this uh
AI we should have taken the script and
and done it there you go good morning
Robin good morning Howard how are you
feeling today I'm feeling great thanks
for asking you know it's always a good
day when I get to come in and do this
show with you I feel the same way Howard
that's what makes it so much fun we just
have a natural connection and it comes
through in the show yeah we have a great
chemistry on air it's like we can read
each other's minds this feeling is
mutual Howard I agree and you know what
Robin you're not just a great co-host
you're a great friend I'm lucky to have
you in my life you're more than just a
boss you're a friend too and I'm
grateful for everything you've done for
me oh you're making me blush Robin I
knew this was bogus as soon as you asked
me how I was and I said I'm feeling
great right I was like who's who am I
working with
Robin you are so beautiful to me I agree
I agree yeah I feel this way
I feel the same way and I am very
grateful to you my boss I mean AI woof
very very dull radio show